how are you doing here I remember you we
were in Miami together everywhere you
did the trailer launch in Miami
everywhere always showed love I'm always
following you always been there for us
for the highs and lows when we had
nothing
when we were dirt poor we were trying to
run up here
you helped us
and and the Queen Latifah would say stay
out the ghetto why are you always acting
up when you come over here
listen here's the thing though I'm gonna
start calling you the master of
manifestation because then like this you
saw this and you went from this little
movie about street racing to nine movies
later and you're in at a Premiere in
front of the Coliseum in Rome
I was gonna say that but
Hannibal Barca
Road
an African elephant over the Alps and
never entered Rome
we do
don't judge it
was too much gold the parallels are
crazy stop it it's bananas and then you
know I gotta I gotta get you I gotta ask
you right here because
um Meadow they love you
[Applause]
I was talking to Meadow earlier you know
she teased and she showed us she showed
us this photo of a cameo of hers in the
movie what does that do for your heart
foreign
there wasn't there wasn't a day outside
that I don't remind the cast and the
crew of the weight
why we need to retire
why we need to make this film with
integrity
we
I'm waiting for after this Premiere to
hear Pablo telling me what he always
told me after everything which is
there a better one in the can which was
always the motivation to get to here
to have Meadow here
have Meadow do a cameo just to honor her
father
it's just
it's just an another layer another
color to what I can only describe as
Destiny it was perfect it was perfect
Before I Let You Go real quick we didn't
get to get you at Guardians of the
Galaxy but how special because you were
doing what you do but how special was it
for you to be able to record that line I
love you so people now know what group
was saying you know just
on that front
it was very cool because it meant that
the audience
was now able to understand
the vernacular the language
of this Flora Colossus and that's a
testament to the 10 years
of
loyalty
which we've been so blessed with right
this franchise with the group character
um
and patience to have people wait that
long for
yeah somebody for 10 years of someone
just saying three monosyllable words but
like everything in life with patience
and dedication
you know good life my man
always we got you we got you
[Music]